[Musica]
[Applauso]
Siamo qui per parlare di
tempo ma che cos'è il
tempo Beh possiamo dire che il tempo è
qualche cosa di intress secam connesso
col
cambiamento se nulla cambia il tempo
esiste A questo proposito Aristotele
aveva una opinione bella
Chiara se nulla cambia il tempo non c'è
semplicemente così in
realtà ci vuole perché nulla cambi per
esempio nella nostra vita di tutti i
giorni anche se Stiamo seduti
spaparanzati su un divano Basta che
abbiamo una finestra di fronte e vediamo
in continuazione
cambiamenti il sole le nuvole la pioggia
tempeste tormente di nuovo il sole c'è
sempre qualcosa che cambia e non è un
caso quindi un caso per niente che ai
cambiamenti dell'atmosfera che ci
circonda Noi abbiamo dato lo stesso nome
del tempo che passa tempo il tempo
meteorologico e il tempo meteorologico
ovviamente cambia e nella sua natura
come abbiamo appena detto
ma cambia Ma si ripete anche lo sappiamo
benissimo Ci sono ciclicità
un'estate sarà più o meno simile a
un'altra estate è completamente diversa
da un'altra stagione da un inverno
Quindi in tutto ciò c'è cambiamento e
nello stesso tempo regolarità
cambiamento e regolarità insieme fanno
stabilità qualche cosa che noi pensiamo
essere stabile e questo qualcosa che
pensiamo essere stabile questo
cambiamento continuo e regolarità lo
chiamiamo clima un clima stabile or bene
il clima della terra è stabile No non
c'è nulla di più sbagliato da pensare
che il clima del nostro pianeta sia
stabile e sia sempre stato stabile non è
così pensiamo semplicemente all'ultimo
milione di anni
come moltissimi di voi sapranno ci sono
state le grandi glaciazioni Le grandi
glaciazioni che hanno sono avvenute sul
nostro pianeta con un periodo di circa
100.000 anni l'ultima è avvenuta 20.000
anni fa e pensate 20.000 anni fa tutto
l'emisfero Nord a partire più o meno
dalle nostre latitudini Quindi circa
intorno ai 45° i continenti erano
completamente coperti di ghiaccio nella
letteralmente nella morsa del ghiaccio e
vabbè tantissimo tempo fa ma vediamo
Andiamo un po' più vicino guardiamo un
po' da vicino gli ultimi 2000 anni li
vediamo là in quella diapositiva quello
che vedete sono le variazioni della
temperatura globale terrestre quella
curva nera che state vedendo rispetto un
periodo di riferimento questo periodo di
riferimento e sono gli ultimi 50 anni
del 19 secolo
1850-1900 Ebbene Cosa vedete vedete che
è sempre cambiata la temperatura da 2000
anni ci sono state piccole oscillazioni
su e giù eccetera però c'è una cosa che
subito subito Salta gli occhi quello che
è successo più o meno negli ultimi 150
anni vediamo che quella curva lì quella
curva scura che state guardando Io non
la vedo ma la conosco a memoria ce l'ho
di spalle bene Ha subito un'impennata
un'impennata pazzesca È la prima cosa
che ci salta agli occhi noi vediamo quel
grafico non vediamo tutto il resto Ma
vediamo quella cosa lì e quella cosa lì
è successa negli ultimi 170 anni ed è
successa a una velocità che non
ha riscontro che non negli ultimi 2000
anni e ha raggiunto una variazione che è
di circa 1 gr centigrado che non abbiamo
mai visto negli ultimi 10.000 anni ma
andiamola a guardare meglio quel eh
Questi ultimi 170 anni li vedete ancora
là
c'è in quel grafico vedete tre curve
quella eh scura nera che sono le
osservazioni negli ultimi 170 anni a
partire dal 1850 fino al 2020 poi ci
sono altre due curve una arancione e e
una verde Che cosa sono queste sono
curve che sono le medie di
simulazioni numeriche avvenute con
modelli
di del che descrivono il clima terrestre
i cosiddetti Earth System Models questi
modelli sono in grado di riprodurre sia
al tempo che il clima a partire da certe
condizioni Ebbene come vedete la curva
arancione e la verde vanno bene con
quella delle osservazioni fino a un
certo punto più o meno fino al
1960 Dopodiché quello che succede È la
cosa seguente la curva
arancione continua in linea con la curva
nera la curva verde
No completamente diversa Ebbene Qual è
la differenza la differenza è
fondamentale importante ci riguarda da
vicino perché Perché i modelli che che
hanno contribuito alla curva verde sono
tutti modelli a cui abbiamo totalmente
nascosto l'esistenza del cambiamento di
CO2 di concentrazione di anidride
carbonica in atmosfera che è aumentato
rispetto al periodo preindustriale è
aumentato di quanto Beh di parecchio
pensiamo che al giorno d'oggi la
quantità di CO2 in atmosfera è del 40%
più grande rispetto al periodo
preindustriale quindi di parecchio la
curva verde non lo sa mentre la curva
arancione in quei modelli lì lo sanno e
solamente mettendo questo contributo
Cioè a facendo aumentare l'anidride
carbonica in atmosfera riusciamo a
riprodurre quello che è successo e
quindi e quindi questa è la prova che la
causa dell'aumento di temperatura di 1
grado è proprio questa l'aumento di CO2
dovuto
al alle attività umane che sono le
attività legate all'inizio della seconda
rivoluzione industriale cioè l'uso di
combustibili fossili per tutti gli
aspetti Legati all'industrializzazione
una cosa bellissima che ci permette poi
di essere qui seduti coi nostri
cellulari con tutte le nostre cose
stupende che però ha avuto questa questa
conseguenza uno però dice Bah cosa vuoi
mai che sia un grado di temperatura di
più di meno che cosa vu dire realtà
praticamente Beh intanto diciamo subito
cosa non vuol dire un grado di
temperatura media globale sulla terra
non vuol dire né che è un grado
dappertutto né che è un grado sempre ci
sono delle cose diverse e in più e
questo è molto importante cosa si
trascina questo grado di temperatura
media globale in più con sé si trascina
una cosa che C che ci riguarda
tremendamente che riguarda la nostra
vita di tutti i giorni perché con un
grado di temperatura in più C'è un
aumento nella frequenza di eventi
estremi nella loro
eh e e nella e nella loro diciamo
gravità Cosa sono gli elti estremi Beh
facciamo degli esempi semplici un evento
estremo è un'ondata di calore eh
pazzesca abbiamo saputo delle
temperature record per esempio che ha
toccato nel 2021 il Canada siamo andati
oltre i 50° per fare un esempio oppure
per esempio un'altra cosa sono casi di
ehm piogge estreme pioggi talmente
talmente torrenziali che producono poi
inondazioni tutti questi sono eventi
estremi E ce ne sono anche di altro
genere di tempeste violente eccetera
eccetera Ebbene questi eventi aumentano
proprio proio sono trascinati in aumento
dall'aumento di temperatura globale
anche se l'aumento di temperatura
globale lo vediamo diciamo Ma cosa
volete che sia è poco In realtà ha tutte
queste conseguenze queste conseguenze ci
riguardano ma vediamolo un po' più da
vicina qui mi devo voltare Scusate Vi
darò Qualche volta le spalle ma sennò
non mi ricordo
e Allora prendiamo come esempio gli
estremi caldi vi chiedo di guardare quei
puntini quei puntini
sia sulla grafico a sinistra sia a
destra allora un evento estremo è per
sua natura un evento raro che che
avviene raramente Allora prendiamo dei
tipi di eventi per esempio molto caldi
un evento che nel periodo
1850-1900 avveniva in media una volta
ogni 10 anni e invece un evento ancora
più estremo che avveniva una volta ogni
50 anni bene Guardate cosa succede già
al al tempo presente 1 grado questo
evento si è moltiplicato avviene di
media ogni volta tre volte ogni 10 anni
e 6 volte Ogni 50 anni ed è più caldo
nella caso di 10 anni è 1,2 gr più caldo
nel caso di di 50 pure circa 1 grado più
caldo per cui se noi andiamo avanti con
le proiezioni diciamo Cosa succederà a
1,5 a 2° a 4° vedete che il numero di
eventi numero di pallini aumenta aumenta
e alla fine a 4° se immaginiamo un mondo
a 4° quell evento non è più estremo non
lo possiamo più considerare estremo
perché avviene ogni anno in 10 anni e e
40 anni su 50 in 50 anni e non solo è
molto più caldo è 5° più caldo Quindi se
l'evento è per esempio un'estate torrida
o delle delle temperature record
immaginate che queste temperature record
saranno di 5° più calde quindi questo
vuol dire In pratica per cui questa è
una cosa L'altra cosa che senza andare
tanto agli eventi estremi guardiamo
invece la normalità vi ho detto prima il
grado non è un grado dappertutto come
vedete in quella mappa grande con
scritto osservazioni questo è
praticamente la fotografia di come le
variazioni di grado di 1 grado di
temperatura sono distribuite
nel mondo e come vedete c'è molto più
aumento di temperatura a nord
specialmente nel Circolo Artico che a
sud e più nei continenti i modelli fanno
qualche cosa che si assomiglia quindi
diciamo Beh tutto sommato sono
abbastanza affidabili e quindi andiamo a
vedere a
differenti livelli di riscaldamento
globale cosa succede e quello che
succede lo vedete lì già a 2° e 2° è il
limite che ci siamo siamo posti come
comunità mondiale con gli accordi di
Parigi del 2015 che non vogliamo
superare Perché dopo non sappiamo bene
cosa succederà vedete che già 2° ci
dipingono un mondo in
cui le variazioni di temperatura nei
continenti Possono raggiungere anche i
3° di media e addirittura verso i poli
sono intorno ai 6° 4° non lo vogliamo
guardare non lo vogliamo guardare perché
ci dipinge un futuro che eh in cui molta
parte del pianeta potrebbe essere
totalmente inabitabile Ma noi quel
futuro lì non non lo vogliamo non lo
vogliamo raggiungere e non lo
raggiungeremo perché abbiamo tempo tempo
per cambiarlo e infatti quanto tempo
abbiamo per cambiarlo Guardiamo questo
ultimo grafico che sembra un po'
difficile ma non lo
è vediamo gli anni dal 1980 al 2100 e
qui abbiamo in Gig tonnellate le
emissioni annuali di anidride carbonica
fino al 2020 seguite Quella quella linea
nera e poi dopo abbiamo delle curve che
ci
rappresentano fondamentalmente rispetto
a quando Noi cominciamo in quanto tempo
dobbiamo ridurre le emissioni di
anidride carbonica per stare sotto
questi due gradi per stare in sicurezza
Ebbene vedete che noi nel 19 80 e
mettevamo 20 Gig 20 Gig tonnellate
l'anno e siamo le abbiamo raddoppiate
nel giro di 40 anni Ebbene Se noi
vogliamo stare sotto i 2° dobbiamo
andare alla velocità doppia perché
dobbiamo arrivare al 2040 di nuovo
intorno ai 20 milioni e quindi dobbiamo
andare almeno due volte più veloci se
avessimo cominciato nel 2000 avremmo
potuto e lo sapevamo queste cose che vi
ho mostrato i grafici che vi ho mostrato
non erano molto diversi da quelli che
sappiamo adesso avremmo potuto andare
con più tranquillità più lentamente
quindi impostare delle politiche di
comunque transizione energetica verso
un'energia rinnovabile più facili adesso
siamo a un punto che dobbiamo fare in
fretta dobbiamo fare molto molto in
fretta
perché perché non abbiamo tanto tempo
per non F cambiare il
tempo
[Applauso]
Grazie